this leads me to some a broader
discussion that I want to have with you
about neoliberalism about liberal media
so-called neoliberalism is not dead by
any means as a result of the election of
Donald Trump there are questions about
whether the Democratic Party as an
establishment may have been killed by
Donald Trump we have more and more
concern about the middle class and
income inequality and the destructive
impact that huge corporations can have
when they are totally unregulated
broadly Americans are more concerned
about those issues to some extent Occupy
Wall Street played a role in bringing
those issues to the forefront but then
we also need to talk about this idea of
neoliberalism which is a policy model of
both social studies and economics which
transfers control of economic factors to
the private sector from the public
sector that's sort of a general way that
we can think about neoliberalism and
that's going to play a major role in the
Trump administration we have a
businessman with no political experience
whatsoever who number one is planning to
run the country like a private business
even if you look at something like
Donald Trump's infrastructure spending
idea he has taken something which is
normally associated more with the
Democratic Party the idea of using
government spending on infrastructure to
at least temporarily create jobs and
improve the sort of Commons that we have
in the country on which business can be
built that's normally more associated
with the American Left Trump has figured
out a way to co-opt it but turn it into
crony capitalists bidding in a way that
will derive huge profits for some of
these construction companies etc etc we
talked about that but it's more than
neoliberalism being represented in the
Trump administration because he is going
to run the country like a businessman he
is simultaneously pursuing business
interests at least during his time as
president elect Donald while doing
politics and diplomacy and whatever
else so what could the impact be of all
of this on the Democratic Party well the
Democratic Party as we know it could die
and by that I mean the DNC is a business
it also ran the primary like a business
they chose the product ahead of time as
opposed to letting the buyers decide
fairly they lied to people about their
role in choosing the product saying hey
we're not here to pick candidates we're
just here to run the primary we later
found out they were actually putting
their hands on the scale for Hillary
Clinton and the Democratic Party Pat has
been hugely discredited in a number of
different ways including that dishonest
primary but the real issue now is can
the Democratic Party reframe in a way
that at least relates more to the
support we saw for Bernie Sanders and
there was a deep desire for a candidate
like Bernie Sanders and less like
Hillary Clinton doesn't mean a hundred
percent Bernie maybe it means 60 Bernie
forty Hillary or something like that and
that's going to be a big thing for the
next two and four years my own things
have changed in the past couple of weeks
I mean we thought that the other
Republicans would have a really tough
time winning a national election again
and that Paul Ryan was gonna lose the
speakership and now things have just
shifted completely we didn't even get
the Senate it's a very very different
scenario and there's also questions
about the future of the Republican Party
right I mean the Republican Party is
clearly not dead because as Pat mentions
they won the house they won the Senate
and the White House however what is the
impact going to be of a Donald
presidency on the party you had some
major Republicans not supporting Trump
some of them have come back around
partially because Donald Trump seems to
be at least intimating to them that they
might be in the running for some nice
cushy positions Republican voters voted
for the guy who is a Republican by name
but also supports some major policies
that Republicans typically don't want I
mentioned major infrastructure spending
I have talked in the past about not
getting involved in the Middle East to
the same degree that neoconservatives
have liked to over the last couple of
decades and then the final question is
what happens to liberal media I'm not
going to get into that again because I
gave my sort of liberal media rant
earlier in the show I will remind you
that our program has really exploded
since the election of Donald Trump on
November 8th on every platform setting
records every single week records for
paid subscribers some of the other
progressive independent house have
reported similar upticks
up ticks and we have to see whether this
remains during the donald trump
presidency or whether this is just sort
of an initial push an initial excitement
from progressives because they realize a
lot is at stake here that may wane I
hope that that doesn't happen
we're going to be here certainly and
this is going to be not only to try to
push the President to not make
disastrous decisions but also to push
the Democratic Party to make good
decisions for the next couple of
election cycles